I'm Nick
Freeeeeeaakin
Woo, Cage!
[Therapist] What's
the worry here, Nick?
You've lost some of
your talent as an actor?
No.
(Nick scoffs)
What did he say?
[Ted] He says
he loves you, but
he went in a
different direction.
[Nick] I'm done.
I'm quitting acting.
[Ted] Ah, man, I'm
driving through The Hills.
I'm sorry.
One more time?
We got another offer.
It's a million bucks.
It's to attend a wealthy
gentleman's birthday party.
[Nick] The guy
that owns this house,
-What's his name?
-Javi.
-Mr. Cage.
Excuse me, is Javi
going to want me to uh,
-you know?
-I'm not sure I understand.
Look, Javi...
I am Javi.
Nick Cage.
God, this place is stunning.
What is your favorite movie?
That's one of those questions
that's impossible to answer.
You can't just limit it to one.
♪ Imagine me and you, I do ♪
[Javi] Is it too much?
[Nick] Is this
supposed to be me?
It's grotesque.
I'll give you 20,000 for it.
♪ I can't see me
lovin' nobody but you ♪
♪ For all my life ♪
I didn't know
that was a cliff!
We could have died!
(Nick laughs)
(intense music)
I'm in position.
[Ray] I think that's
the actor, Nick Cage.
Nick Cage!
I love you.
Have you seen Croods 2?
[Ray] I'm 44 years old!
Why would I have seen Croods 2?
I've seen Face Off and Con Air.
What do you guys want?
We're with central
intelligence.
Do you know who you're
spending time with?
One of the most ruthless men
on the face of this planet.
I need you to help
the U.S. Government.
(heavy exhale)
♪ Let's kill this ♪
Find a way into that room, Nick.
[Nick] I can see myself
doing more of this stuff.
I think I might have
a real gift for it.
Good, because we got
another mission for you.
No, no, no, no, no.
Your friend is working
for the U.S. Government.
Don't lie to me!
Are those my golden guns?
They're my golden guns.
I don't wanna kill you.
You're the last
person I want to kill.
I Love you.
I love you!
♪ You'll just be silly ♪
♪ Gimme dangers ♪
I'm Nick
Friggiiiiiiiiiiiin
(Nick screams)
Ow! Wooo! Cage!
(intense music)